I represent the data science team at
Open Table how many of you have actually
used OpenTable to make reservations oh
that's a fair amount so we are very
popular
um so before I begin I just want to say
that I used to be an astrophysicist
before now I'm a data scientist and the
common thing that's between the two
carriers is Python and data so I'm
really indebted to the pi data Community
for making that transformation you know
translation pretty easy so coming back
to open table as you know Open Table
um is an app or a platform to make
restaurant reservations primarily so we
connect diners with about 32 000
restaurants both in the US and no
worldwide and then
um you know we have a pretty nice set of
um you know traffic so basically we have
receipts about 15 million diners each
month to our system our diners ride more
than 400 000 reviews
every month so that's you know I can
sort of start to see that over the
lifetime of the company company we have
accumulated a lot of data but it's only
recently that we're moving into data
science and doing something with the
data to enhance the experience of the of
the diner so essentially um there's this
big move at OpenTable to move from being
just a transactional company which lets
you book a table at a restaurant to more
of an experienced company so suppose
you're you're walking and you want to
get up find a place for dinner you'll
get recommendations for restaurants
which are tuned or tailored to your
tests not an alphabetical list and um
also like if you travel to a new city
the you know system knows about your
preferences so it'll it'll suggest
restaurants that are attuned to your
taste also you want to know about you
know sort of what restaurants are about
so if this restaurant is a restaurant
which is about amazing views and amazing
seafood and this is this other
restaurant which is very meaty it's
about like barbecue and steak you want
to know that without having to go
through say 2 000 reviews
right so um we have a ton of data in
various different forms you know like I
think when I think about the data we
have it's really like it covers the
whole slew of data kinds of data you can
work on in data science so you have the
reservations the transactional data we
have the search location where people
are searching where people are you know
looking for restaurants we have images
of both interior of the restaurants and
the food items we have textual reviews
people write you know pretty extensive
reviews on our platform
um and you know the reviews are very um
sort of you know because
the customer has to go and actually eat
at a restaurant and to write a review
they're they're much more you know
believable and then there is uh there
are restaurant ratings obviously people
go on rate restaurants and the ratings
are also granular in the sense that
people can rate
um food Ambience service separately and
then there are menus that we have and
there are many other you know aspects of
the data that we have so it's a very
rich data ecosystem that we live in at
Open Table and the main you know sort of
idea of going forward what we want to do
is to give you that magical experience
of dining and which really
requires connecting the dots between
understanding the diner very well and
also understanding the restaurant so
basically you know on the diner side
from your explicit or implicit
interactions with our system would build
level profile a few on the on the
restaurant side we want to know what a
restaurant is about whether the
restaurants is you know good for a date
or it's family friendly or you're really
into like restaurants with views and so
basically it's basically a matching
process between the diner and the
restaurant and you know all these comes
um sort of as a recommendation stack but
it has a lot more to it because there's
so many different types of data that I
already talked about so there's textual
data there's
um you know like visual like images and
also basically there's also location
like if you're a frequent traveler we
want to recommend differently than if
you live in one place
things like that so basically I picked
two themes for this talk because of
limited time so one is what we are doing
with analyzing the review the textual
content that we have and then also what
we're doing in terms of making
recommendations and one is linked with
the other so you know I put them in that
order so we have a lot of reviews as I
said
and they come in all shapes and sizes so
there are very small reviews like a
single word called superb you know and
then there are views which might read
like someone's biography it's like
really big and long and really like
explains every aspect of the dining
experience
so you have all these reviews and um so
how do you make sense of reviews so for
example you know Slanted Door which is
one of you know a very um popular
restaurant in San Francisco it has like
over you know 3000 reviews you're not
going to go and read all the 3000
reviews but it turns out that whatever
people are writing in their reviews they
can be summarized into themes so people
are not writing about 200 different
themes in their reviews but they're
writing about the food they're writing
about the ambience about the service so
there is this inherent um sort of
feeling or you know like structure of
having themes around which people talk
in their Diner reviews
so for example here are some sentences
that I plucked from some of the reviews
so the first one the first two which are
in blue you can pretty much see that
it's talking about the food
but the second and the third and the
fourth they're basically talking about
the Golden Gate Bridge View so it's only
talking about the views and the last one
it's talking both about the view and the
food right
and so um so so think of now not in
terms of sentences but of reviews each
review is sort of generated from week
what we call data scientists called
topics and so you can think of a way in
which a review is generated from
a few handful of topics in a
probabilistic way right and this is what
is called topic analysis in in the sort
of machine learning uh parlance
um so basically what we did was we
looked at the Corpus of reviews and and
we looked at first uh you know broken
down into geographic regions because we
thought there might be Regional nuances
to the way people talk about things and
then we classify we learn the topics
which are inherent in the reviews
through topic analysis
um
you know which I'll go into and then um
you immediately see that these topics
fall into categories like food Army and
service and so forth and then what you
can do is you can go to a restaurant and
see what topics are the highest weighted
topics for these restaurants if you go
to a restaurant which is situated by the
bay and has amazing Seafood you will see
the seafood topic and the view topic
really bump up but these topics are not
being learned on a restaurant by
restaurant basis this is being learned
from the global Corpus of all the
reviews that you have for that
geographic region right and then what
you can do is you can relevant you can
Surface only the relevant reviews which
is related to the topic you're
interested in so if you're interested in
going out and eating meat so click on
the meet topic and it will show reviews
that are only relevant to the topic so
you don't have to go through the 2000
reviews to see inside you know like what
people are saying about the meat at that
place
so this is sort of the general uh idea
of topic analysis so what you have is
you know every document is sort of
generated probabilistically from certain
topics and each topic is a probabilistic
distribution over words basically and
without going too much into detail here
to essentially think of like you know a
review that's talking about seafood and
and and and Views there are two topics
out there which which is about Seafood
which is about views and the words are
sort of being probabilistically
generated from those and you're getting
the review in the end so you basically
apply this backward and from the reviews
you go back to the handful of topics
that you know can you know have
generated all the reviews on our system
sort of
um so this is uh there you know there's
a way of going after it through
non-negative Matrix factorization and
for that the python you know python has
amazing tools already so you could we
basically used Panda psychic learn
there's a tool called gen Sim which lets
you do latent derision layer location
which is also which is one of one of the
main ways of learning topics and then
there's the nltk which is the natural
language toolkit which lets you do
stemming and lets you do all kinds of
you know fun stuff uh with before you
actually put that into a topic Learning
System
and some of these techniques were also
porting over to apogee Spark
so this is like you know how you can
learn topics in three lines so basically
get your data do account vectorizer
using scikit-learn
you know then you basically transform
your reviews into bag of words model
I actually do a TF IDF if you know that
what that is before I get into this step
and then you just call the
composition.nmf
um so and out comes this uh like topic
Matrix which is essentially number of
documents by topic weights and then you
have this other Matrix after this
decomposition which is Topics by words
so every topic is a distribution of
words and here I'm showing some of the
topics that come out in the SF barrier
so you can see the first one is about
fish and chips and Tacos the next one is
about Ambience it's saying noise level
is very difficult to hear conversation
the third one is about Bay Bridge
moonlight so it's like about views the
server was knowledgeable or helpful then
there's the shushi topic by itself
parking being difficult or easy there's
Value Parking there's a Sunday brunch
topic the crab cake topic you know
anniversary wedding special occasion
topic right so we learned about 200 of
these topics and then we categorized
them into food drinks Ambience value
service special occasion and there are
some generic topics which has to only
deal about I went to a restaurant right
so we throw them out
um then you know you can have this
really nicely categorized topics and
then um we can do various things with
these topics so first thing I looked at
was you know whether there were some
Regional variations between the topics
we learned so you can basically see that
if you look at the view topic like the
San Francisco Bay area is very much you
know very well endowed with views so you
get more than one topic that talks about
views there whereas in Chicago people
are talking about you know basically
looking out over the lake uh look from
you know like some tall building and in
New York people are talking about views
of the Hudson River in London it's a
Thames Bridge you know the Saint Paul
Tower so basically um there is a lot of
like nice stuff that you can learn just
from looking at the topics for example
there is a thing in in UK called Sunday
roast which you don't find in the US so
us people talk about Sunday brunch right
and then people talk more about wine
pairings in the US whereas they talk
about wine matching in the UK so it's
kind of really nice how you know natural
language is uh kind of you know people
refer to the same thing in different
ways in different places and then in the
UK there's a topic on Indian food by
itself which is not very surprising
right so you can actually go to
um a fine dining place through OpenTable
and have Indian food which is not that
prevalent in the U.S and then there's
the Yorkshire pudding topic and all this
and people go to you know a restaurant
pre and post theater so that's the
theater topic there on obviously in the
UK there's the afternoon tea right so
you get all these things you know coming
out from this simple exercise of doing a
topic analysis and then you can look at
all the topics that's visiting your
restaurant the single restaurant and you
can do a weight over the topic
distribution of that restaurant and you
can say oh this this restaurant here is
is about you know this prime rib and
rebuy it's very like meaty restaurant
and you know maybe uh I mean there are
like 10 topics that only makes sense to
this restaurant the service was pretty
good the noise level was very high and
then you can only surface the reviews
when you say you know when you're only
interested in the prime rib topic it'll
only you know surface the reviews that's
relevant to that so it's a very nice way
of pruning through the topics but we
went one step further and we said you
know like are there dishes so basically
from these topics we can also learn
about what people are talking about in
terms of dishes they mention a lot in
the reviews uh there are if there are
dishes which are very very Regional that
you don't find anywhere else so
basically think of this as a set
subtractions if the state of all foods
that sort of you know Global and then
you subtract it from it all the foods
that in that's in all other cities
except this city and you're left with
something which is very you know
indigenous to this city here I'm ex you
know like example I'm giving is Toronto
there you can find something called
flower pot bread so basically they
actually bake the bread inside a flower
pot
there is a duck poutine pizza just you
know like sir the heart attack served in
a pizza but uh must be delicious so
basically you know I'm just
trying to exemplify how starting from
just a simple concept of learning some
topics you can take this in various
different ways and make it very engaging
right and then if you look through UK
you know in Edinburgh of course haggis
makes a lot of uh you know has a lot of
weight in there and you can see nicely
that you know in the south of UK people
are more talking about seafood and fish
whereas you know in London it's more
about emus Bush and all the sort of a
very fine dining kind of things
so from this kind of topic analysis what
we wanted to do is to find dishes that
are mentioned a lot of times in the
reviews and then basically find out what
are the popular dishes at this
restaurant right so the way we went
through this exercise was we took the
food topic so you could you could just
think of doing an engrams count right so
I go to the review and I see which
engrams which three letter words are
repeated many many many times but there
is no guarantee that those three letter
words would be about food
so we could descope the words that visit
you know that vocabulary by actually
taking the words that fall in the food
topic because you already categorize the
topics as being food and then learn the
most
um frequent engrams that you know are
within that set of words and from that
we got a huge amount of dish tags like
you know like crab cake appetizer
flourless chocolate cakes this just come
out of this analysis and then we have a
way of sort of you know like mechanical
turking the false positives out so you
get a very nice so we had already a very
nice list of n grams but this
significantly improved in in and
expanded the vocabulary that we started
with
and now
we can do this so this is within the
OpenTable app where you can actually go
to so this Bluetooth is a restaurant
right here in Manhattan and you can go
there and it'll show you these are the
popular dishes and then for each of
these dishes you can link back to a menu
a review where we can see what people
are saying about that dish right so this
is a very nice way of sort of
summarizing the restaurant to you and
and get giving you a sense of what this
restaurant is about but dishes are not
the only things about restaurants you
care about Ambience you care about you
know other attributes so we basically
came up with you know a finite set of
attributes that we wanted to learn and
then we go in the reviews and we apply
logistic regression to learn what sort
of um talk you know attributes people
are talking about in the reviews and
it's the same restaurant again and it
says you know it's known for pre-free
menu we have a great service it's good
for birthdays so this is a nice way of
summarizing the entire restaurant to you
with without you having to read all the
review content right and the sort of um
you know devil is in the details because
you know sometimes it's not very obvious
what people are saying in the review so
these these kind of machine learning
algorithms to be smart enough to say
something like when someone says I love
the relaxed feel it's dark small cozy
dark can be a very sort of negative word
but it sort of figures out that the
person is talking about dim lighting
right so it's it's basically by learning
sort of you know how people use these
words when they describe certain things
and then you can also if you if I know
nothing about you but if I only know the
restaurants if you you have visited over
your lifetime I can build up a profile
of you just by looking at the attributes
of those restaurants so this is our CTO
Joseph ASAS and I made a profile of him
so he visits restaurants which are you
know fit for Foodies he's a foodie and
he obviously does a lot of business
meetings so there's good for business
meeting is one of the attributes in the
restaurants he goes to
um you know he goes mostly to kosher
restaurant that comes up in sort of the
restaurant metadata of the restaurants
he visited so from this you can also
start
building up sort of a profile of the
user and then you know you can go one
step further and look at the reviews and
see what are the sentiments people are
you know expressing and what are sort of
the ingredients of a very Stellar review
so we took all the awesome like five
star reviews and we asked what are the
predictors of a good review what what
words do people use when they're
actually you know giving a restaurant
five stars right and you see you know
it's recommended is a big word excellent
I recommend definitely delicious you
know presented very beautifully so you
can sort of look at it you can see like
this is you know these are the
ingredients of a very good review and
then you can flip it and you can also
see what are the ingredients of a very
bad review and you'll see that salty is
like not a very obvious word right but
salty comes up a lot when people talk
about a bad review
um it obviously disappointed service was
slow waiting for a long time and this
other word which is okay food was just
okay you know so we say okay okay A Y
okay it comes up so basically just by
digging into the textual information
that we have we are you know seeing all
this very nice insights right and and I
just wanted to give you leave you with a
taste of what kind of stuff we can do
with uh with just textual data
so moving on
um so we don't want to just stop at you
know learning what restaurants are about
and what users are about but we want to
connect the two so we want to connect
restaurants with users or with diners so
essentially
um what are the ingredients for a
recommendation engine at a place like
Open Table right so you have the diner
restaurant interactions so the
previously you dined out you gave them
some ratings or you searched for some
restaurants on our system or you left
reviews and many more and then there's
Cuisine the price Lane range of the
restaurant that matters to you maybe
you'd never go to a very high-end
restaurant
um the location and what are the topics
of these restaurants this restaurant is
about seafood or if this restaurant is
about romantic atmosphere might be
important to you and then there is the
user profile kind of where I talked
about is like what you know what sort of
you know your demographics are and those
things
so
so traditionally uh collaborative
filtering is the way to go um for doing
recommendations but there are a bunch of
approaches here that have enumerated so
there's the nearest neighbor app
purchase where you find users that are
similar or restaurants that are similar
there's a content-based approach because
you know so much about the restaurants
that even if you have visited only two
restaurants we can Surface similar
restaurants to you and this is very
useful for cold starting a set of people
who have very little interaction with
our system
and then finally what we're building
right now is our factorization machines
which can actually include all these
things in like one nice uniform
um formulation
so if I don't know how much time I have
I probably have five more minutes so
I'll just go through quickly so everyone
knows about collaborative filtering I'm
sure so basically you have
the explicit case where you have
actually left a certain rating for a
restaurant and then you have many
restaurants you haven't interacted with
for which you want to know the predicted
rating and typically what you do is
basically break it down you do a matrix
factorization kind of approach
you break it down into end diners by n
factors and in factors by in restaurants
matrices but the factors are really like
say maybe 200 or so so the idea being
that each of these factors are latent
reasons why you went and gave that
restaurant a five star and then once you
multiply it back it fills in the missing
cells in this Matrix and then you can
rank them by the ratings and recommend
the top ranked items right so that's how
it works usually but you know
we don't you know we have ratings from
people but we have many other signals
people search for restaurants right and
so that's where the implicit
um preference is coming so basically the
fact that you're searching for
restaurants at 50 times is a signal to
me that you really want to go there you
really probably want to you know like
that restaurant and so then it becomes
sort of an implicit preference
formulation and there's a very uh it's a
classic paper which is like who Quran
and volinski which we have implemented
at Open Table which is um basically take
the actual raw count and
take a one plus Alpha times rij which is
we call the confidence so basically
always say what we're saying here is
that the fact that this person has
searched for this restaurant gives me a
preference one that this guy has a
preference for this restaurant but how
much you weight that when you learn the
latent factors is given by the
confidence so if you have searched only
like five times I give you much lower
confidence to get that right than if you
search for something 500 times right and
it's very nice
um approach so we have implemented this
um so first we you know like obviously
massage the data sets with a lot of
pandas and by you know python tools but
finally uh it goes into a spark machine
learning library called
ml lib it's a very nice Library so if
you're using spark um it's very it's a
very powerful tool and we use the
alternating least squares algorithm to
learn little factors we optimize for
position at K because we are inherently
doing a ranking algorithm here so we're
ranking by preference
but then what do you do with the users
who have very little interaction with
their system right so if if this guy
went out only two times in their Open
Table lifetime you know all they're
going to get out of a collaborative
filtering is mostly noise so for those
people we came up with this
content-based recommendation system so
suppose this guy went out to mediocre
Indian restaurants two times the only
two times he booked through open table
so we can what we can do is we can learn
so because we have all this metadata
about the restaurant so we know what's
the average star rating is we know it's
an American restaurant here you know
Financial District we know the location
we know the price range is 31 to 50 it's
pretty pricey restaurant right and we
have we know the ratings over all these
uh granular aspects like food service
Ambience we also know the attribute tags
of these restaurants that this is fit
for Foodies you know it's a special
location place so for every restaurant
we have this information
so given that this guy has gone to two
mediocre Indian places we can basically
surface more mediocre Indian places to
this guy right but suppose you're this
other guy who goes to high-end French
places but only like cheap sushi places
right so because we have this metadata
even from those two interactions I can
Surface a mix of the two kind of
restaurant but it and also the way it
learns we use a Bayesian approach like
some information retrieval approach it
does not actually stay within the
cuisine that you visited but it also
awaits the other aspects so maybe you
went to that French restaurant because
it was like it had amazing Ambience
which was romantic so then it was
actually surface a few more romantic
restaurants even if they are not French
so that's kind of what we do
um
and we see uh lift in a b tests and
stuff with doing that and finally we are
using uh sort of building uh
factorization machines so I don't know
how many of you have used this in
recommendations but this is a very very
powerful way of including side features
into a recommendation system so here
instead of having one Matrix which is
user and items and then the cells are
values you basically you know
unravel The Matrix into this huge Matrix
where you have one zero zero zero as
being the user and the second in the
Orange is the restaurant in our case
right and then the third and the fourth
blocks can be things you know about the
user things you know about the
restaurant and at the end the target is
the preference that you already know for
this user item interaction and then you
can throw them all in and essentially
what it does it's basically a logistic
regression in the end
but before doing that the trick is
because these matrices can get really
really big right because you know
suppose you have 3000 restaurants and
who knows 10 million users so this each
of these rows will become that long
right
so what it does it actually factorizes
each of these rows into smaller latent
factors first and then it uses those
factors to learn the prediction that's
why it's called a factorization machine
and it has been shown to work you know
like it's like one several kaggle
competitions with this so the challenge
here is you know taking this so there is
a library called lib FM which you can go
and download and use it's a c plus
Library
um
but the problem is it's written for an
academic scale data set so and it does
training and testing at the same time
and there's no way to store the models
and use it later so we are actually
breaking into the code right now and we
you know basically found out a way of uh
saving the models we're using the mcmc
approach in there and then sometimes you
get this amazing nice moments of Joy
where you can write all those equations
in this one line of python code using
sci-fi sparse operations
it's kind of cool so you can do the
prediction of the entire set in just one
line which is kind of cool
so but you know to scale it up to the
sort of you know uh say the entire us
for us uh we are putting over the
factorization machine to Apache spark we
are actually uh also partner partnering
with database brics Cloud so which is a
cloud platform that lets you use the
spark within sort of a notebook like
environment which has been really useful
for us because as you develop you want
to see so basically imagine you're
running an IPython notebook over your
entire data set in ec2 and you know
having and doing all the operations over
rdds which are basically you know like
memory
um sorting the data up in memory
it has been pretty useful for us so far
so things that we want to do in the
future is more on the sentiment analysis
and the reviews we want to do what's
trending in a certain city at a certain
time so you can you know like really
give you an uh a word you know like
basically you can get an email saying oh
kale is trending right go go and get or
Dungeness crabs are in town and then um
and obviously a full recommendation
stack would be something like an
ensemble of all those models that I
talked about so we are getting there
um you know just take one minute to um
you know um advertise this so I'm a
member of this uh organization called
Bayes impact which is a non-profit which
is trying to use data science for social
good it's it's got a lot of traction
recently
um so if you are any of you are
interested in working on problems some
of these problems are you know one
finished project is Parkinson's disease
disease stratification of patients uh
improving organ transplant
outcomes there's a very very nice uh
impactful social problems that we are
working on with the healthcare with the
government directly so just reach out to
me if you want to contribute or the
basically they provide a fellowship for
you to go there and work with them for
six months to a year and work on a
social problem it's really awesome
so with that I'd like to thank you